hello there are welcome to Council of
geeks my name is Nathaniel Wayne and
tonight I am joined by Paul scavino and
Ryan Daley and in honor of the upcoming
release of Spectre a movie that I think
we're all excited about we are going to
talk about James Bond in general
specifically we've all got our picks for
our personal favorite James Bond film
and we've all picked one what we feel is
an underrated Bond film we flipped a
three sided coin earlier which means
Ryan gets to go first a three sided coin
it always comes up Hales okay so my
first favorite the first preface this
I've seen about 12 of the 24 but I don't
think I don't think any of us have
actually seen all of them not quite all
I've seen most of I've seen most I'm
missing a couple I've seen about half of
them more of the more recent ones from
Timothy Dalton onward sure and then a
few of them oh I have no doubt that true
bond aficionados who hear or watch this
are going to lose their minds um that
said favorite is actually going back
into the Roger Moore catalog and it's
the spy who loved me for one thing the
Bond girl Anya amasova I love her story
she's a KGB agent James Bond actually
kills her husband in the opening
sequence which is a skiing chase
basically down the mountain so it's a
great set piece to kind of start off the
movie she finds out later that James
Bond killed her but she has to work with
him for part of the plot so she's
promising okay as soon as this mission
is over I'm going to kill you because
you're my blood enemy so it's got that
classic relationship but of course he's
James Bond so well I'm going to fall in
love with them and they end up sleeping
together well what a break from the
forum exactly is that another element
that I love about it is the super
villain sort of Bond villain is
essentially a super villain he's got an
undersea base like an undersea
laboratory that looks a lot like the the
headquarters of the Legion of Doom
meanwhile at the Legion of doing exactly
it's got yeah it's this weird sort of
bug shaped thing that kind of Rises out
of the water so I just I love the
atmosphere of a villain having an
undersea lair it's just great he's gonna
you know set off these bombs he's
capturing submarines to instigate World
War
his henchmen is jaws I think it's the
first time that we see jaws his first
big yeah yeah the first time I saw him
which was not in that movie but the
first time I saw him in the movie when I
was a kid he kind of scared the crap out
of me he's just got this horrible
Frankenstein lurch figure with these oh
no so just terrified and I think it's
like he comes up again and again in this
movie and they keep fighting and he
keeps looking like he's going to die
it's pushed off of trains he's dropped
into a sharpie oh the villain has a
shark tank well of course he does
because of course and jaws has dropped
into that shark tank and you know who
wins jaws and I'm not talking about jaws
the shark was like yeah okay I love this
so there was just a lot of that and then
probably the third greatest highway the
real reason that it sold it for me is
it's for my money it's got the best Bond
theme song Carly Simon's nobody doesn't
matter Thom Yorke from Radiohead called
that the sexiest song that was ever
written and considering it wasn't
written by Prince no definitely
Paul my favorite it's an easy one again
Goldfinger yes so much the template
Lon's
it is I mean it's like cheating it's guy
was the first one that I saw right and
it's got all these unbelievable classic
moments in cinema not just in Bond films
you have bombs strapped to the table
with maybe the most iconic scene one of
the most iconic scenes in the film you
have the you know the emergence of all
of the Bond gear you have this
relationship with cue you have the you
know the again iconic scene of the girl
coated in gold on the table you have I
think one of the more interesting set
pieces ever built which was the I don't
know 30 foot by 30 foot Fort Knox rising
out of the floor model which I have
always envied and want it you have a
character named [ __ ] Galore who leads a
team of pilots you have odd job and
I think the best thing about [ __ ]
Galore though is not just the name its
bonds reaction to it
she says I'm [ __ ] Galore knows I must
be dreaming if he said that I would have
been an eye roller but the fact that
that's his reaction like okay yeah now
that's now that's just perfect I
honestly cannot think of a moment in
Goldfinger that I don't enjoy and and
there are some critiques about things
slowing down and you know that there are
parts of the film that we don't assume
to see I think from start to finish
though it is an unbelievably good time
now for me my favorite is actually
Skyfall because every performance on
that is spot-on I that film is gorgeous
I think it is one of the most
beautifully shot films of the last
decade I think that is a stunningly
gorgeous film the song is incredible
that film just wrapped me up so much and
and for my money it was such a wonderful
marriage of the harsher edged bond that
we had been getting with Daniel Craig
just leading into what what we're going
to be getting respect about leading into
the bond world as we knew it previously
I love that that bridging element I love
Judi Dench's am and who I've always
liked is M but I think that was her best
performance in that part and and even
the side characters moneypenny's great
and ray Fiennes as new m is great it's I
I just loved the heck out of that movie
and while I'll admit the logistical
problems I just don't care and Javier
Bardem has Silva is probably the best
Bond villain that I've seen he's right
up there I mean sort of it part of it is
the legitimate Menace that he feels the
the blood vengeance but actually and
this is something I'll come back to when
I talk about my my underrated one I love
that the motivation for the villain is
personal yes any other thoughts on the
favorites no let's get to underrated
okay I'll start off you're done then and
it's die another day mm-hmm
it's the Pierce Brosnan one the last one
that he did I do think the Madonna song
at the end of the movie is the worst
James Bond song ever if not like the
worst song recorded probably that year
it's got this interesting hooked at the
beginning where he's captured I think
but North Korea yep and thrown
for like five ten years or maybe maybe
I'm exaggerating but the song isn't
great but I do like that the the opening
credits are over are superimposed over
images of him being tortured yeah
welcome to this and look the the mi6 has
disavowed him and everything and then
but basically eventually they trade him
back and there's a whole action sepia so
you got this weird plot with the bad guy
who you think his dad was like the son
of this North Korean general turns out
he just went through like a skin
grafting thing where he turns into a
white Caucasian maybe was diet was a
flawless accent is that some kind of
commentary I don't know I don't want to
delve into that I think another reason
that people kind of kind of disavow it
is because the inclusion of the one who
plays jinx which is Halle Berry did
nothing of her name and she was hot for
a while and then at some point everybody
just turned on her but she's she's good
she's fine movie I don't think the part
is written very well but no I think yeah
if he/she was an okay addition I really
liked the other Bond girl who is the
villainous Rosamund Pike who's just like
the white queen she's like dying in
theme she's a fencer there's no like a
lot of really cool stuff there's this
whole like battle in the middle of it in
this ice palace in the Arctic and of
course there's a super laser and then
they're going to use to wipe out all of
the land mines between North and South
Korea but that is as the doomsday weapon
so that the no marine army could just in
rate it's like okay there's a lot of
weird stuff going on but there is a
really cool fight in the plane with this
guy who's got like this glove that's
just like full like shoots electricity
there's a lot of weird stuff in it and I
like again as I'm saying this this
sounds ridiculous but there's just
something watchable about it and I
really liked Pierce Brosnan's
James Bond I think ultimately the
problem with that movie was not any one
element but it was how many of those a
little outlandish they were because
that's that's the thing you can get away
with the ice palace or you could get
away with the Sun laser or
you could get away with the invisible
car or you could get away with the the
Paris
surfing thing at the beginning trying to
get away with all of those in the same
movie right I think is what broke the
back of this thing I wouldn't mind
watching it again and that's kind of
where I come down line it's my
underrated pick that's fair we're
skipping you we're coming back to you we
really need to end with you from my
underrated it's another Brosnan which is
the world is not enough okay and the
thing is I think in the wake of Die
Another Day I think a lot of people just
wanted to write off all of bras and
except for Goldeneye so now this one
this one had head Denise Richards yes it
did it I'll get to that I'll get to that
what's your name Christmas Jones Yes
Doctor Christian of course I think the
things that are good in this movie are
actually like some of the best in gone
which first of all is the song hmm I
love that song that garbage did that
yeah yeah yeah and it's phenomenal the
other thing that I really love in this
film is the main villain not Robert
Carlyle because he's the henchman
ultimately but it's sophie marceau
mm-hmm who is initially set up as the
love interest and then later is revealed
to be the mastermind behind everything
that's going on and I love her for a
couple reasons the first is a bit like
with Silva and with Javier Bardem even
though she has a plan with huge
implications and there's a lot at stake
ultimately it's very personal what she's
doing and I love how badly she got under
bonds skin cuz you can see it in his
face because he's first half of the
movie he's putting his neck on my he's
almost dying trying to protect her prey
and when she turns and she's jeez
torturing him you can see how much this
really gets under his skin and I think
that's perfectly epitomized and actually
the fact that he shoots her dead in cold
blood what's happening is he's got her
at gunpoint on the phone trying to get
her to call off the plan and he says
tell him to stop or
gonna shoot you and what she says over
the phone is go ahead with the plant any
shoot sir she was thrown ahead and she's
dead and that's it and it's so
cold-blooded but felt so what she put
him through then I'd love that now it
causes a problem because it means the
entire climax of the movie we're not
dealing with the master and we're
dealing with the henchman noob you just
didn't know to stop which takes the
stakes out a little bit now as far as
Denise Richards goes I actually don't
think she's as bad a Bond girl as people
think I think she well here's the thing
I think she fits the general type fine
the mistake that they made was saying
that she had a PhD in in nuclear
physicist physics that was the problem
and it was a problem that came out of a
reasonable goal which was let's make a
smarter Bond girl and there's nothing
wrong with that but if that's what
you're going for you don't cast in East
Richards and as far as the name I don't
think the name is any stupider than any
other Bond girl name it's now but it's
clearly set up for the punch line up
like the last line of the movie and it's
clear like you get to that point your
legend yeah we were waiting for this
line out there I yeah I enjoyed that
movie I that is one of the better bond
ones especially from the Pierce Brosnan
era and I do I like that more than that
another day a lot of work I just begin
for that reason it's not on my
underrated list but whatever I find
myself in a bond discussion or a bond
forum or whatever people throw it under
the bus like you wouldn't believe
yeah my thing with the Pierce Brosnan
resin films though is that I don't have
a lot of desire to go back and watch
many of them I enjoyed watching them at
the time but I don't have a particular
compelling interest to go back and watch
those films before I let Paul say what
what he's about to say here
I need to buy need to preface this
because when I first suggested this
topic that we all pick an underrated it
actually occurred to me to say flat out
nobody better try and defend this movie
in my home the thought actually occurred
to me nobody in their right mind would
ever try and defend this movie so you
never disappoint me Paul
what is your pick for an underrated Bond
film ladies and gentlemen I'd like to
talked about Moonraker
when did the Bond films have to get so
damn serious right and so this is one of
the things that I loved that I loved
about Moonraker is that if we if we look
at the Bond films now right we take us
to no Casino Royale
then we take Skyfall and we take what is
the second ourselves no I don't think
that's its name the one of which we do
not speak um and we take those movies
they are so dreadfully serious right and
they're just this dirge and there's
fight scenes that are black and white
and like and it's just death and mayhem
so Moonraker this is how Moonraker opens
right is we have our pre um title scene
with James Bond in a plane putting the
moves on a stewardess and she delivers a
line that is much higher Mr Bond and my
ears might pop as he's sliding his hand
up her side to which I go he and then
she pulls a gun on him right because um
because bond because it's James Bond
right and he doesn't look particularly
upset or even surprised it's just again
thanks and out of the cockpit walks the
pilot with a fantastic fake mustache and
these dark aviator glasses and he's
wearing a parachute it's very clear
what's about to happen and he turns
around and he shoots a bullet into the
console and well the planes gonna go
down and James is just sitting there
leaning back on the couch inside of this
plane he doesn't look concerned at all
he hasn't even changed his posture
because he's James Bond right and he
knows he's gonna get out of this right
and it's so much fun now it lead now so
this is the the opening moments right
and then it leads to him eventually
getting they get into a fight he and the
pilot right and he gets thrown out of
the plane by jaws
yeah Enzo jaws is back and he's tossed
out the plane without a parachute and so
we have this amazing sequence of James
falling through the sky and he's gonna
die oh wait but there was a villain
thrown out ahead of him and so what his
James do he squirrel flies his way over
to the head guy they fight in the sky
over the parachute James eventually gets
it kicks that guy to his eventual death
like okay James is okay but no Jacques
has jumped out so for your money were
you did you think that one sky fight was
enough no no this movie delivers two and
the second sky fight between him and
jaws that he does eventually win and
jaws goes to pull his parachute out and
he rips the the ring out and he falls to
his death into a circus tent and of
course not he lives the the thing that
people why people hate on this film
right is because it's James Bond in
space also there is a scene that takes
place in Venice where he is driving
around a hover gondola now I laugh you
might but James Bond who's a resourceful
agents and when the need calls he has at
his beck and call a hovercraft gondola
1977 we have the release of Star Wars
this movie comes out in 1879 it's very
clear they're trying to capitalize on
the popularity of Star Wars and I mean
there's no question at all it's
basically like wow a Star Wars was
really popular was a blockbuster
could we put James Bond in space well
why can't James Bond go to space and in
fact if we needed somebody to go to the
space what do we want James Bond to be
the one that we would send into space
yes is the answer to that right and do I
want to see James Bond in space yes what
to see teams won and seas beating up all
the villains of the bad guys because who
else would send right into space but
James Bond
long story shirt also Oh actually let's
back up there is a love story between
jaws and a character named dolly I don't
know why that's in the movie by the end
of the film
it gets revealed the Drax's plan was to
wipe out the earth by using this toxin
that he was going to launch into the
upper Earth's atmosphere and he was
going to wipe the planet out and then
repopulate it with the perfect race why
do I love this film because Roger Moore
I think it's an excellent James Bond we
get to see him in his glory in this film
it's about technology a self-assured
James Bond
it's not about fight choreography right
you know James is going to win right
it's about the fact that he's got this
kind of smirk a punch right a clever
idea or solution to the problems he's
gonna get the girl and there's usually
several for him to choose from over the
course of the film and throughout it all
it's just fun to watch it's entertaining
as create it's crazily entertaining to
watch this film I have not seen
Moonraker put that out there I haven't
seen this one but I have strong thoughts
and they're mostly just about Holly
Goodhead so it's actually dr. Goodhead
course it is okay you you have chosen in
your mind to say the reason people crap
on this is because it's Bond in space
and you are wrong it is not because it
is born to space people crap on it
because it is a cartoon parody of what
Bond film you completely glossed over
the tram fight allow me to paint this
picture for you
bond and dr. Holly Goodhead which I
teach is really doctor cuz she's a CIA
plant to be an astronaut so I think
that's a fake doctorate so they're there
in this they're in this tram they're at
some crazy height above the earth jaws
stops it with his hands so it's now
staying still he bites one of the cables
and it breaks but nothing Falls that
that bite was just to show off his
ability to bite so rather than biting
the rest of the cables until the thing
falls when they pumped to their death he
handover hands it
the cable to the car to get into one of
the most unenthusiastic fistfights
I have ever seen in my life so
eventually this fight she and James are
sliding on a chain down the cable the
tram jaws has gotten the thing moving
again so he's now basically chasing
after them with the tram and they as
they get close enough to the bottom they
drop and they make a safe he crashes
into a building to then be rescued by
this woman literally half his size in
blonde pigtails who is going to be his
love interest and the reason he betrays
the villain because he finds out well
she's not part of the master race so
she's not in the blend so i betray you
Drax for tiny Swedish meatballs girl
this this thing this is like a template
for James Bond jr. that's how
preposterous this is now that gondola
okay if you're look I did not rewatch
this movie because I am too much
self-respect but I rewatched the gondola
chase because I remember hating it first
time I saw it and I just want to see was
it as bad as I thought it was no it's
worse because well before we get to the
point that it's hovering across the
venice squares all right we'll take
pigeon yes the pigeon does a double take
after this thing okay but we'll ahead of
all that he he's got a little young
motor so he's got it he's got a
speedboat gondola fine cool I'll go with
that
but again just making the point this is
a cartoon parody a bond he slices
through this other gondol of that
genuine gondola that has lovers on the
front end the gondolier on the back the
gondolier Sanks sinks and the lovers who
are making out just float off and
they're fine when when it turns into the
hovercraft and gets up onto the onto the
street the villas just stand there
dumbfounded in their own gondola now
there's nothing stopping them because
they've got a motor on there's getting
close enough
to get up onto the onto land and catch
this thing because it's moving at a
brisk walk pace there's nothing stopping
them from getting this but no they have
to turn their speedboat around and one
of them fall off into the water girl and
the other one cause immediate find some
ridiculous accent and no dude no I think
you counter with the center few she
Center huge seem where extra few Sentra
easy for you to say centrifuge see we're
in James is merely killed in a center
bution okay if we've got what Skyfall
and Sarah Ellen one end and Austin
Powers and in life twins
this is way closer to closer to those
that it is to any other Bond film yes I
think so
you're absolutely right the film was
filled with problems I admit that the
reason that I think that I like this
film is that there is this spirit at
least in the film of fun and and of
being with a self-confident cocky
James Bond who knows is going to win
right and and who and has that kind of
swagger to him despite all of the flaws
that are in the film but I admit there
are many about the one thing that I
won't knock is Roger worse performance
because you're right he's got the
swagger he's got the confidence that's
fine but everything around him is
cartoonish I can't think of any other
word other than cartoonish hey mark my
words we will see James Bond in space
again maybe not in this ghost movies in
James Bond will return four times 25 in
Spain boy I think I think we'll wrap it
up there what did you guys have that you
wanted to plug this time around
okay now that neither of them have
anything that they're ever doing ever
again thanks so much for joining okay go
ahead a number of podcasts that you can
find me on the Secret Origins podcast
which is available on iTunes and
stitcher dedicated to the DC Comics
series secret origins a Star Wars
podcast called ed boffin spies which is
available on iTunes and Paul and I are
working on the webcomic
red and green which is going to be
making a resurgence at some point in
2016 it is you can find me in places
such as dramas and films
I'm Matt Rick's but I'm also the writer
for Rising Sun comics property called
armadillo justice which I think one of
the first issues has come out take the
first issues out yeah so anyway um so I
guess that's about it thanks so much for
joining me guys
alright until next time this council is
adjourned